okay so the topic of this video will be
the difference between gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria so let's get
started
so here is a diagram of a typical
bacterial cell and I want to note the
three layers that most bacteria have
their innermost layer colored green here
is the plasma membrane which directs
what enters and exits the cell it's a
phospholipid bilayer with some proteins
scattered in between the phospholipid
bilayer the middle layer in gold this is
the cell wall which provides structural
support to the cell made up of a
polysaccharide called peptidoglycan the
cell walls really the most important of
the three layers when it comes to
understanding gram-negative and
gram-positive bacteria the third red
outer layer this is the capsule it's
more of a sticky outer layer for
attachment and protection but like I
said I really want you to focus on the
cell wall so let's get started so let's
do a little compare and contrast gram
positive versus gram-negative bacteria
grandpa's they have an innermost plasma
membrane and there it is in my drawing
and the gram-negative bacteria also have
an innermost plasma membrane so there it
is so there's our phospholipid bilayer
the plasma membrane now the gram
positive bacteria have a thick cell wall
made up of peptidoglycan and so there it
is kind of five layers thick right there
in my animation the gram-negative
bacteria also have a cell wall it's just
thinner so there it is only two layers
thick in my animation now again these
are both the cell wall of the of the
bacterial cells when we look at the
gram-negative bacteria they also have an
additional outer phospholipid bilayer an
additional outer membrane and now we
come to the third layer called the
capsule the sticky outer layer so
there's the capsule for the gram
positive bacteria
and gram-negative also have an outer
capsule so there's the capsule for the
gram-negative bacteria as well well one
thing to mention is gram positive
bacteria more easily treatable with
antibiotics simply because gram positive
lack that second outer a phospholipid
bilayer there
therefore the gram negative bacteria are
harder to treat with antibiotics simply
because it's harder for the antibiotic
to gain entrance into the bacterial cell
eventually we're going to talk about a
Gram stain and when we do we're going to
mention that gram positive bacteria
underneath the microscope appear a
violet purple color after performing
what's called a Gram stain now the gram
negative bacteria after performing a
Gram stain appear reddish the pinkish
color underneath the microscope and
we're going to explain why this is in
just a few moments so let's talk about
this process known as a Gram stain now
the purpose of a Gram stain is to help
identify whatever infectious bacteria
that is getting us sick and so the
reason we do this is because treatment
will differ based upon the outcome of
this Gram stain and so when we look at
the steps we're going to break this down
into a variety of steps number one we're
going to obtain bacteria from a culture
and using an inoculation loop we'll
transfer bacteria onto the inoculation
loop and then we're going to smear the
bacteria across a glass microscope slide
so the next step we're going to do is
we're going to fix the bacteria to the
slide so they don't get washed away when
we do the upcoming steps in the Gram
stain and we're going to do that by
taking our glass slide and we're
actually going to pass it over an open
flame a few times and the heat will fix
the bacteria to the slide as I said this
way they don't get washed away when we
start using some of the chemicals in the
latter steps so the first chemical we're
going to use is a chemical called
crystal violet and like the name implies
it as a purplish violet color so we'll
add a few drops of crystal violet onto
the bacterial samples and once we do
let's zoom on in and take a closer look
at the cells of the bacteria that are
trapped on this glass slide and when we
do we see that we have the gram positive
bacteria on the left and a gram negative
bacteria on the right now at this stage
we don't know which bacteria in our
sample are gram-positive and
gram-negative I'm just labeling them for
our ease and simplicity so right now all
we've done is we added the crystal
violet those purple molecules were added
and they pass through the layers of the
bacteria into the actual bacterial cell
and then the next step is we're going to
add iodine iodine kind of has a brownish
goldish bronzes color and here come the
iodine molecules and they actually pass
through the layers and they actually
bond and bind with the crystal violet
molecules that have previously entered
and they kind of clump together and and
make the molecule bigger so the next
step is to wash the bacteria with
alcohol alcohol as a destaining chemical
and watch what happens to the gram
positive bacteria on the left the cell
wall will shrink and the capsule kind of
gets dissolved and and washed away now
for the gram negative on the right the
same thing with the cell wall this
a wall kind of shrinks but notice how
that's the capsule and the outer layer
the outer phospholipid bilayer that were
washed away this is because of the
dehydrate of nature of alcohol and now
here is a big thing that happens watch
what happens next because of the alcohol
wash because the cell wall is so thin
for the gram-negative bacteria the
crystal violet iodine molecules also get
washed away
so the gram-negative lose their color
underneath a microscope right now if we
were to view the bacterial samples the
gram-negative would look transparent and
have no color but the gram positive
bacteria would appear a purple violet
color because they retained the crystal
violet dye so the next step is to apply
a kind of a reddish colored molecule dye
called safranin and so here's safranin
being added and what happens is the red
pinkish safranin molecules up pass
through the cell wall and actually bind
with the lipids of the lipid by the
phospholipid bilayer and so now we can
actually see the results of a Gram stain
underneath the microscope underneath the
microscope the results appear the gram
positive appear purple in color now you
might be asking yourself why is that how
come they don't appear pink because they
have safranin in them as well the reason
is simple that the saffron and the pink
color of the safranin is just
overshadowed and masked by the deepness
the darkness of the purple crystal
violet so you don't even really see the
pink safranin in the gram-positive
bacteria it's there you just don't see
it and notice how the gram-negative
bacteria because they lost their crystal
violet dye and they only have the
pinkish safranin the gram-negative
bacteria underneath the microscope would
appear pink in color so here are some
actual
teachers of a gram positive bacteria
notice the dark purple color and some
pictures of gram-negative bacteria
notice the reddish pinkish color so as I
wrap up this video I just wanted to put
the two side-by-side one last time pause
the video if you want to read through
the text again but the reason a Gram
stain is so important is knowing whether
a bacteria is gram positive program
negative we can then begin proper
treatment as the notes say gram positive
are more easily treatable with
antibiotics that's because they only
have the one phospholipid bilayer the
gram negative bacteria are more
difficult to treat that's because of
their dual phospholipid bilayer so there
you go pause the video if you're still
reading and post your comments in the
thought and in the box below I hope you
found this video helpful thanks for
watching